the Iraqi capital of Baghdad suffered
greatly following the us-led invasion in
2003 and from the growth of the ISIS
terror network that followed but now
America and Iraq have claimed victory
over Isis and that declaration has had a
tangible effect the ancient city has
been brought back to life but with new
tensions in the region some wonder if it
can last Roxana Saberi reports from
Baghdad for years this was the Baghdad
broadcast around the world a city shaken
by battles and bombs images that
residents fear could be repeated if
tensions between the u.s. and Iran
dragged their country into a new war a
year and a half since Iraq declared
victory over Isis the Iraqi capital is
edging toward normalcy with traffic jams
and people strolling in the streets
walking through these streets much less
at night and without a flak jacket and a
helmet we did coordinate with the Iraqi
security forces ahead of time come on
down
still the authorities insisted on giving
us a police escort
because as foreign journalists speaking
with local residents we clearly stood
out a boon Ashwin told us these days he
feels relatively secure how concerned
are you that this security would be
shattered if Iraq is dragged into a war
by the u.s. and Iran very worried he
said we are fed up with war so at
Baghdad Operations Command general sad
man says he prefers to focus on
preventing the reemergence of Isis also
known as - we are a war and sustainable
war against - and against terrorism this
is back he says Isis still threatens
parts of the country but for now Iraqi
security forces are keeping the capital
called when was the last time Baghdad a
deadly car bomb or a deadly terrorist
attack
Motul on more than one yeah more than
one year ago honey around a half maybe
in the streets of Baghdad we saw how the
general who used to be on TV bringing
bad news about terrorism is now treated
like a celebrity from the winning team
everybody knows you yeah a security has
improved Baghdad's landscape has changed
these blast walls were built to protect
against the car bombs that used to rock
Baghdad on a daily basis they were a
symbol of just how dangerous the city
had become now they're coming down but
they aren't being destroyed because they
may still be needed assign that while
the city is growing confident it remains
cautious how safe do you feel
80% safer than before Ronny a fella told
us God willing it will get even better
Iraqis realized that depends not only on
them but also on the u.s. and Iran
keeping their country out of another war
for CBS this morning Saturday Roxana
Saberi Baghdad you know and war is being
waged right in your backyard you have a
very different perspective the last time
Americans have seen that kind of combat
was what the Civil War interesting to
see that they've taken the blast walls
down but they're not destroying that
good that's what's about to me